if you thought the Twitter feud between
President Trump and Kellyanne Conway's
husband was going away anytime soon
hey think again George Conway retweeting
all kinds of new attacks against the
president today including suggesting
that Trump is mentally unstable
this comes as Kellyanne Conway's once
again siding with her boss over her
husband my husband also has been very
critical the president publicly which is
unlike him just because he's
traditionally been a very private person
in 2016 which was known as the year of
the tweet
George Conway sent exactly zero tweets
so this is new and what also is new is
not supporting the agenda of the
president and my work there
I was raised though in a household of
strong Italian Catholic women who taught
me that you air grievances like that in
private so it is very surprising to see
it be so public so this is so
interesting to me because I mean it's
like an addition we should start a show
I think you said this yesterday called
the Conway's it's unbelievable but if
it's real what Kellyanne said to Maria
Bartiromo was she's never really
addressed this with her husband they've
only talked about it in passing
meanwhile George Conway says oh he gets
the tweeting out so he doesn't have to
scream at his wife what do you make of
it well in my notes for this block as
you can see I literally just drew what
is a dumpster fire um I think it would
probably be best for if someone doesn't
want a topic to be covered that they
just refrain from speaking about it I
think the more content put out by all
three of those parties is unfortunate
and it's distracting from larger issues
at hand and also their credibility
Jessie he says some really strong things
about the president you know whack job
and he's a narcissist antisocial he puts
out all kinds of cycle psychiatric
diagnoses for people to read about the
president and I don't I just wonder you
know how does this impact people who
work from fans what do they think of it
well he should look in the mirror I mean
talk about psychologically imbalance I
don't know what this guy's up to
I like your new hand movements this was
very bad OS this was a new one I've
never seen
milking the goat but like Emily I just
don't have a lot to say about their
marriage it's a private matter and now
it's spilled out to the public and it
looks humiliating for everybody involved
but I would say Kelly and Conway is
handling it gracefully she's a very
intelligent woman a very passionate
woman for the president and I hate to
see her embarrassed by this it looks
like George might have Trump derangement
syndrome and maybe he's angling for a
CNN contributor ship I don't know what's
going on I kind of don't want to know
what's going on
right and I hope we could all move on so
Dana as this is taking place the
president's feud with the Republican
Party seems over John McCain continues
and it's almost like people are saying
well you know what we don't like that
guy I think the president's feud is with
John McCain and there have been I don't
think the other people in the Republican
Party are not feuding with the president
about that some of them some of them
like congressman Dan Crenshaw are saying
please mr. president just stop it like
he's not your political enemy like you
suban
on the Conway step one thing I think
about this is III agree I I don't I kind
of I wish we didn't know but here's the
thing
George Conway wants us to notice he's
poking the bear and I don't understand
to what the desired outcome right so
what do you want to happen you're not
the first to say the president has a
narcissistic personality disorder what
do you think you're going to accomplish
that you're going to be able to do that
nobody else is able to do by saying the
same thing like what do you want do you
want to make life harder for your wife
at the White House do you think it
doesn't affect her at the White House do
you want President Trump to be able to
paint you as a worse husband than he I
mean this is an incredible situation I
wish we could just not talk about it if
she but if she I think she said he would
like her to stop to leave the job I
don't know I must have missed that all
right all right so Greg what do you
agree with you I love every minute of it
yeah I want it to keep going no it's
interesting we always talk about this
being like a reality show he's actually
trump has been able to come back to
combine a whole bunch of different shows
because it's like a soap opera with a
lot of subplots you know it's like I've
Farrelly Brothers version of Falcon
Crest first Trump is basically jr ewing
right but the ant but then pence
he's Ned Flanders right he's Ned
Flanders Bolton is obviously Matlock and
then Kelly and her husband they could be
kind of like the Furley from Three's
Company but he's more like Newman and of
course brian Stelter is Costanza always
complaining about the better-looking
people over at Fox News and I understand
that but the thing is the real
development here is that we are talking
about it this was going on for a while
so it's kind of moving towards a
resolution and I'm dying to I can't wait
to see what it is how this is gonna end
this is like it is like who shot jr. go
ahead get into it I can't wait for the
finale honestly we need more of these
maybe at the finale we'll all wake up
and find out it was a dream was a dream
we're all in the shower
that's doubt terrible death Dallas
husband from hell though I don't know
who gets that title